as autochtones parce que nous nous
intéressons aux jeunes alors là c'est
les très jeunes ils ont moins de trente
ans il y en a trois ici bonjour à tous
bonjour jean vous avez vous avez moins
de 30 ans ok c'est bon c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais qui ottawa coué mais qui est
mais qui vous avez vous aussi moins de
30 ans 28 ans 28 quelle jeunesse
et puis mathis mathis cas elles aussi
moins trente ans il a bien ici alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est vous
qui est à l'honneur dans cette émission
là aujourd'hui parce qu'on s'intéresse
donc à ces jeunes autochtones donc on
comptera pas matisse dans le lot qui ont
moins de 30 ans et qui font des choses
hyper intéressante et c'est votre cas
mais qui vous êtes une artiste est ce
que l'on peut dire vous êtes une artiste
multidisciplinaire vous touchez à plein
de choses
oui multidisciplinaire je touche à la
vidéo
les illustrations l'installation la
photo
puis l'animation aussi on a beaucoup
parlé de vous dernièrement entre autres
à cause de cette fantastique là
incroyable jeu murale qui maintenant
trône en plein coeur de montréal sur
alanis obomsawin qui est cette cinéaste
abénakis bien connu pourquoi est-ce
qu'on vous a demandé de faire cette
murale comment vous a approché pour ça
ben en fait c'était un appel à la
candidature de c'était pour ils ont
choisi ma maquette t c'était vraiment un
appel à soumission puis ils m'ont choisi
parce que c'était mon appart est ouvert
à tous ce qu'ils ont aimé mes cd puis la
maquette que j'avais faites vous la
connaissiez à l'anis va vous la
connaissez pas ce qu'est la miss
évidemment elle est toujours avec nous
et heureusement vous la connaissez
alanis obomsawin way we were
personnellement ou à travers sa terrasse
en allemand mais je les croisais à
quelques reprises domaniecki toujours
aussi aussi charmante et cool
louis matte est toujours aussi créative
ce qui est votre cas aussi alors vous
mais qui vous êtes une attikameks
originaire de manawan
ouais comment l'art est entré dans votre
vie l'art est entré dans ma vie quand
j'avais comme ça fait très longtemps que
j'aime beaucoup dessiner puis tout mais
vraiment je me suis intéressé à l'art
quand je jouais avec la caméra de ma
mère elle avait une caméra genre vidéo
puis je faisais des films avec mes
cousines dans le sous-sol en faisaient
du cinéma genre vraiment vraiment nul
mais très drôle
c'était vraiment des des films d'horreur
des remakes de films de remake de
musique vidéo
je faisais aussi jouait beaucoup avec la
radio de ma grand-mère et j'enregistrais
défaut d fausse émission de radio j'ai
invité des célébrités j'ai vu lewis et
moi j'ai invité des amis chargé des
célébrités à mon émission de radio comme
jean britney spears de cranberries
pisser mes cousines qui jouait les
célébrités
il y avait un engouement pour
l'animation l'acte et une au travers de
tous pourtant vous n'êtes pas devenu
silence
j'ai touché un peu à l'année une dame
aux courts métrages mais c'est vraiment
des trucs abstrait mais je m'intéresse
beaucoup à la fiction c'est en fait
j'écris un peu dans en cachette puis un
jour peut-être que je vais réaliser puis
alors entre vous et nous la personne ne
nous écoute vous parlez de quoi dans vos
écrits en cachette
bah tout souvent c'est s'aider femme mes
personnages sont des femmes ou des gens
qu'on sait pas si c'est un homme ou une
femme puis sinon j'ai je fais des trucs
comme ça puis ouais c'est ça c'est
j'écris d'aider des fictions des jeux
créés aussi beaucoup de personnages mais
je sais pas où les mettre et comment et
genre c'est juste des des fantasmes de
création oui oui vous charme quand vous
étiez jeunes dans votre sous-sol là vous
faisais ça de l'acting le flotteur est
en train de se révéler oui ben arfa moi
je me suis
un souvenir d'enfance j'allais dans la
boutique chez mon grand-père robertson
fourrure et puis je chantais carmen
campagne sur un petit banc et après ça
je passe le chapeau avec avec avec les
gens qui travaillaient là que je
ramassais parfois jusqu'à 100 dollars
mais le comédien on vous il s'est
réveillé quand le comédien s'est
réveillée qu'un ici oui m'a approché là
pour la première fois pour son film
mesnac ses locks c'est là que je faisais
de la musique
à l'époque je faisais des rapides puis
c'est là que ça m'a donné le goût
d'aller de trouver un autre médium pour
pour m'exprimer en fait oui c'est voir
ce coup tellok que que ça m'attire c'est
lui qui me donne un peu la piqûre du
milieu théâtral et cinématographique
ok d'accord mais qui vous comment vous
vous êtes fait connaître parce que quand
bon vous avez d'abord évidemment
travailler lâche et vous à la maison
mais après comment vous êtes arrivé à
l'avant scène alors avec votre travail
binger j'ai fait comme j'ai dit plus tôt
c'est j'ai fait quelques courts métrages
puis j'ai voyagé un peu partout dans le
monde avec ça je suis allé dans quelques
festivals qui c'est comme ça que je je
je me suis lancé dans dans l'industrie
un peu puis après ça j'ai travaillé pour
une solution de paix qu tueuse qui j'ai
fait les séquences d'animation pour le
film lomborg oui oui on a fait l'arrêt
sur le site espace au tapis c'est ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment avec les
collaborations et tout cas que que ça
marche et tout puis ce genre c'est ça
avec la collaboration est le genre je ne
sais pas comment dire je me suis fait
connaître choristes agent je connais du
monde comme ça aussi et puis moi je
mange une question pour toi c'est quoi
être une femme artiste autochtone en
holisme pour toi une femme en 2019 être
artiste c'est
et aux acteurs et aux techniciens
ben moi je pense que c'est c'est
important puis c'est aussi genre s'est
inspiré les autres personnes à faire ce
qu'ils aiment puis surtout gens faire ce
que tu veux tu peux faire tout ce que tu
veux puis être passionné puis c'est un
state mène aussi ces êtres activistes et
c'est tout ça en même temps c'est un
gros travail c est ce que c'est lourd à
porter pour toi je vois pas ça comme
celle où c'est une responsabilité oui
mais c'est aussi genre c'est pas du
travail pour moi c'est c'est quelque
chose qui n'est qui se fait
naturellement
mais est ce que c'est important pour toi
je te tutoie je me permets tu toi que tu
sois femmes artistes mais autochtones ou
ci est ce que c'est important qu'on
relève le fait que tu es une femme
autochtone oui c'est important de d'être
fiers et d'être une femme aussi parce
que il se passe quelque chose dans ce
moment dans le monde les femmes sont
sont en train de serrer les coudes et
c'est il ya beaucoup plus de femmes
aussi qui travaillent dans l'industrie
du cinéma ou dans le monde de l'art d'un
désert puis c'est c'est ce merveilleux
monde alors justement tu fais partie de
ces modèles autochtone qui sont des
modèles pas seulement pour les
autochtones mais pour la société en
général on pourrait regarder le site d'
espace autochtone rêver aux et
construire sur ces jeunes tu vas me dire
si tu en connais certains de ces jeunes
qu'on a présenté une quinzaine de
portraits environs de jeunes autochtones
de partout à travers le pays qu'on avait
envie de faire découvrir
il va me boivin évidemment c'est le
premier qui suit
venture oui vienne manawan dont il
connaît bien lui at on va les regarder
il y en a plusieurs ça vient de l'ouest
du pays évidemment ça vient aussi du
grand nord
ces jeunes là viennent de l'est du pays
du centre thomass géruzet qu ça c'est ce
jeune homme qui travaille à l'université
mcgill celui qui aimerait bien faire
changer le nom des équipes sportives là
les redmen
il ya cet homme qui est incroyable
dunham et qui marleau juke qui veut
devenir une chirurgienne cardiaque
as tu déjà entendu parler d'elle non non
toi charge jamais non plus ses côtés des
nouveaux visages que je découvre les
personnalités des jeux me dit on voit
beaucoup les artistes sont très présents
les voit beaucoup me suis là qui sont
pas dans le milieu des arts qui n'ont
pas la laine
mais cette tribune médiatique le on y
voit pas les on les entend pas cherub
chirurgien cardiaque pour moi c'est
c'est un des plus grands
accomplissements pour les premières
nations vont négocier attriste
autochtones à alison baer c'est
incroyable on s'est tu as bien raison ce
sont des gens dont on entend rarement
parler évidemment une tribune comme ça
ça permet de la deûle et mettre de
l'avant de montrer leur travail pis ça
il va ne boirai flammes en pâmoison
divin de boivin flamand ben c'est un
musicien talentueux qui est chaude à
guitares pire il percevra en tournée
2 n'est plus très longtemps un manhwa
non non non pas du lot
il est sur la route pour pour sa musique
c'est un virtuose et je pense qu'il est
il a appris ça de lui même alors est ce
possible
toi même tu es une artiste autodidacte
on a appris par moi-même
oui j'apprends tout je suis jamais allé
à l'université j'ai juste fait une
session cégeps avait des mauvaises notes
mais j'apprends tout moi même pire est
que tu as bien de ton art oui je suis
travailleuse autonome
je vis de mon arrêt je fais de l'argent
de poche comme ça puis sont passés de
l'argent pour vivre
est ce que tu es connu en dehors du
québec est ce qu on te connaît de plus
en plus ailleurs au canada ailleurs à
l'étranger
un jeu j'ai des amis et je ne veux pas
je pense que oui mais genre plus les
écoles et les gens connaissent plus
maman maman mon travail que moi genre
oui oui oui mais c'est une bonne chose
ce qui est vraiment important il y en a
un charme qui va se faire connaître de
plus en plus et il est tout jeune
c'est un jeune anishnabe kitigan zibi
alors il s'appelle alors à chaque fois
je suis en train de chercher sinon c'est
jacob jacques lavoie
ok on va parler de lui parce que ça t'es
bonne découverte de la semaine
d'ailleurs une joue dans un film we qui
prend la fiche ce soit au cinéma
beaubien à montréal val et à québec il
bouchervillois ce soir donc c'est la
première mondiale qui se fait
s'appelle comment ces films ça s'appelle
une colonie réalisé par geneviève d'une
lutte de sel donc voilà ça raconte quoi
c'est l'histoire en fait de milhas qui
est interprétée par emily bière qui
arrivent au secondaire un peu dans la
quête identitaire d'une jeune
adolescente vit des choses à la maison
tu est exactement là ce récit et puis ça
on essaie de se former une place au sein
de son groupe d'amis c'est pas pareil
comme ses amis ses amis sont un peu plus
flyé était donc à l'essai de se faire
une place dans ce pays un soir il y
arrive quelque chose et jimmy de
personnage de jimmy qui est un
autochtone d'odanak dans le film qui
vient sauver cette jeune fille
oui une relation une amitié se forme
entre les deux et puis il a guesde sur
un chemin différent un petit peu là ce
que lui-même est différent within en
classe dans cette école secondaire là
elle se sent un peu reject un peu à part
mais lui aussi d'une certaine qu'elle
aima les deux les marginaliser oui c'est
ça ces deux extrémités c'est c'est ses
deux extrémités autant culturelle que
que que nouveau sociale donc c'est ça
qui est très intéressant aussi
alors c'est qui c'est jacob whitelock
c'est jacob wade est la voix est un
jeune de quinze ans qui élit anishnabe
son histoire commence quand cueille vu
une annonce de casting sur fiso il ya
décidé de peut-être s'essayer tu n'étais
pas trop sûr donc ça m'a encouragé à
faire aller de l'avant vers ce fait
qu'il décroché le rôle parce que
geneviève dulude a clairement vu qu'il y
avait un potentiel très intéressant et
je crois que nous l'avons vu aussi et
voilà c'est ça fait qu'il décroche le
rôle de jimmy qui est un jeune
autochtone d'odanak dans la dans le film
une vingtaine de jours de tournage pour
lui pour un film à peu près d'une
trentaine de jours et son plus grand
défi ça a été de se réveiller à des gens
d'une habituelle pendant sa tournée
donc il a trouvé ça faisait un peu d'eau
et woippy madison je le vois plus il ya
des fois ya de l'art est un type endormi
on le voit ici c'est bien si il est ami
china b de sa mère il est québécois de
mes coureurs mais lui-même quelle
identité porte-t-il je lui pose la
question si ci avait transmis un peu le
le le certains savoirs autochtones parmi
parmi les gens du plateau par un peu
comme qu'il fait parce qu'ils avaient ce
rôle là ils avaient sûrement il avait ce
rôle là bas dans ce film mais il m'a dit
il m'a répondu c'est juste un rôle
donc je crois pas qu'il y ait caisse je
veux pas m'emballer dans ça mais il ne
peut être pas le plus admiré besoin eu
besoin de faire ça aujourd'hui donc
c'est ça est ce que parce que dans le
voit dans le film parce qu'il est
autochtone on voit qu'il est mis de côté
par les gens de l'école est tous un peu
comme la jeune fille qui elle est
tellement différente des autres
mais est ce que dans sa vie de tous les
jours il a vécu ça aussi je ne pense pas
qu'elle vécut d'agacer sympa je n'ai pas
posé ces questions le niveau 2 du plan
du personnel de commun qu'ils aient vécu
sa vie en tant qu autochtone j'ai
vraiment posé plus de questions sur le
sur son expérience
parce que justement peut-être que ben il
n'est pas qu'un autochtone il est un
être humain c'est pour ça que je me suis
pas vraiment oui je le suis pas aligné
sur ces questions là parce que celle
alors ça revient à jouer le docteur mm
est exact donc c'est lui quand même posé
la question ce que tu as appris à des
gens de ta culture oui toi oui
c'est un personnage donc peut-être qu'il
est pas dans la transmission encore il
est jeune il a king et ses 7 premiers
rôles sans cesse son identité est à être
est affable donc tout est à construire
oui mais il va devenir un modèle dit
aussi quand même bien je vais poser la
question j'ai dit tu devenir acteur il
me dit je suis pas certain mais j'adore
le milieu cinématographique peut-être
devenir réalisateur produit pas donc il
ya eu cet engouement l'eau travers de
tout ça il revenait quand même d'un
tournage quand je lui ai parlé donc
attaquer gagner les jeunes il ya 15 ans
et dans son prochain tournage est ce
qu'on sait quel rôle il a joué non j'ai
pas j'ai pas posé ma foi me papa en lui
même ne pas parler plus donc on sait pas
si c'est un rôle d'autochtones ou non
mais c'est drôle ça sera à suivre alors
à suivre donc le film s'appelle et s'est
présentée à partir d'aujourd'hui associé
au québec
irez-vous le voir ce film parce que
c'est un sujet qui vous et ben je
reviens ou et intéresserait mais qui ben
moi c'est encore et toujours les
artistes autochtones depuis jamais
savoir ce que les enfants
je pense que j'irai le voir donc
présenté à partir de maintenant mais ce
qui est intéressant si je sais que c'est
pas se présenter avec une superbe
sensibilité c'est ça qui est intéressant
geneviève à l'été elle vient du village
de sainte et nikita de village de bannac
c'est pour ça qu'elle allait bien dans
ce film là j'ai comme j'ai comme une
autobiographie une pensée une expérience
de deux geneviève très également donc
elle est rose autochtones 8e n'est tenu
à castries oui oui effectivement il et
puis elle a travaillé aussi pendant
quatre ans comme un cinéaste formatrice
à wapikoni pour appliquer les mots bien
donc
elle a eu ce contact ce lien là avec les
communautés autochtones
donc il s'est approché aussi avec une
certaine sensibilité parce qu'elle est
faite comme qu'on dit dans notre jargon
de journalistes elle est faite vt son
son scénario par le comité jeunesse de
wendake et donc pas de one d'aquedo dana
d'odanak révision et c'est donc et
voulait aussi savoir commun qu'on
représente les communautés dans les
films québécois
donc est-ce qu'on mène à une communauté
fictive est ce qu'on met le nom de la
communauté
donc ils sont venus au consensus qui
était important de garder le nom de la
vraie communauté pour pour asseyez
d'abolir la sous-représentation des
premières nations dans l'est dans les
projets québécois ou dans les films
québécois et allant dans cette terre
d'appropriation culturelle elle s'est
tournée vers les gens qui s'y
connaissent ici qu'elle est installé
leur poser les questions exactement
exactement la fin je pense qu'elle a
fait les bonnes choses que certaines on
peut pas fait elle donc elle a fait le
travail nécessaire
exactement mais qui on va s'en aller
avec et avec mathis du côté du grand
nord est ce que vous connaissez le monde
nordique est ce que vous êtes est ce que
tu es déjà les chalets dans la
basse-côte-nord rencontrer les
communautés innues ouais ça je suis pas
allé plus loin que ça le niveau le plus
loin vous êtes à côté de ces tirs mario
mario et la chatte malioténam ensuite on
inverse
gfr vie mais voilà c'est le plus loin
mayor d'accord est ce que dans ton
travail tu collabore avec d'autres
autochtone oui ça arrive ou et puis
c'est ça bientôt je vais collaborer avec
d'autres autochtones pour pour faire un
des films d'animation puis je travaille
je travaille actuellement aussi avec kim
obame samhain pour son prochain
documentaire je vais faire les séquences
d'animation puis c'est ça j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la
collaboration oui qu'est ce qui
t'inspire dans ce que tu crées dans ce
que tu fais parce qu'avant que la caméra
ne s'allume tu nous parlais des capteurs
de rêves ça c'était une joke que le
gazole je me sentais plus way s'est
beaucoup inspiré par par la musique
beaucoup cette réunion
ouais j'aime la boue la musique
quand je travaille il faut que j'écoute
la musique sinon
j'aime beaucoup aussi il ya tous tout ce
qui m'arrive aussi dans la vie
quotidienne ou
je sais pas du tout comment répondre à
cette question mais ça vient
spontanément aussi oui mais même dans
ton travail comme l'a par exemple pour
la murale d'alanis obomsawin là c'était
un sujet imposé assez alanis obomsawin
mais toi même quand tu crées qu'est ce
qui t'inspire dans ce que tu vas faire
[Musique]
tu t'inspires de la nature des grands je
vais pas bien pourquoi mais je pense que
c'est dans
en tant qu'artiste je peux répondre
assad c'est l'intuition partie
elle peut prendre sept ans le lapi un
moment donné tu finis par faire quelque
chose avec cbc dans le moment si
l'inspiration vient de ton de tous les
jours de ton dos de ton petit train à
tous les jours qu'on voit quand tu
prends le métro quand il prend le métro
à tout les jours dans le monde poignée
dans le monde mais toi peut-être créer
une oeuvre qui suffocante à quelques
parties mouscou ce qu'on s'envoie c'est
donc je pense qu'on cinq ans expire
beaucoup de ce qui nous entoure ce qu'on
touche de ce congrès sens c'est en
réalité elle est ici à montréal
je vis à montréal est ce que c'est de
2,2 du milieu urbain que tu t'inspires
j'habite ici à montréal mais je
décrirais mans mon art comme genre
traditionnel contemporain et puis aussi
georges l'humour aussi ça fait beaucoup
partie de mon travail je trouve que le
sarcasme aussi puis l'humour noir
les autochtones sont beaucoup utilisent
beaucoup l'humour qui cessa animal et
l'imagination aussi c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas reproduire 100%
c'est juste une parcelle de ton
imagination qui tu va capter cette
chose-là puis le mettre sur un sur une
photo un papier puis ça s'est souvent
une découverte de moi même à chaque fois
que je fais un truc louer ou est ce
qu'on le voit tout
hayes alors vous pouvez me suivre sur
instagram
non mais je pose beaucoup sûr sûr sûr
mon surmoi instagram sur facebook ou
sinon j'ai un porte voix lui en ligne
vous pouvez voir aussi j'ai récemment
collaboré avec à oui j'ai une exposition
ce moment comment ça s'appelle le
conseil des arts de montréal oui dans la
mezzanine au deuxième et hg des photos
que j'ai travaillé au mois d'octobre
alors c'est dans quel édifice ses douces
je me souviens principe directement dans
conséquent la maisonnée mis d'accord pis
et non à tout et la formation et on la
donnera oui c'est la prison de quoi
c'est une série de photos que sur les
femmes les les stéréotypes
c'est comme j'entre un magazine c'est un
peu le projet qui avait été fait avec un
collaborations avec d'autres artistes
dans tintin femmes d'autres artistes sur
notre accord avec catherine boivin
bailleurs notamment dernière malo
je sais plus à quel théâtre
quelle maison centre touax respectifs
non c'est pas du tout ça c'est un c'est
un projet personnel et la wii ça c'est
pas disques ou aux copines ouais ça veut
dire les femmes une femme on attikameks
voilà alors on change de direction donc
jeté tout leur jeu disait on s'arrête
dans le grand nord avec un spectacle en
fête qui a lieu ici à montréal a
accueilli matisse à l'appui ainsi
tourner vers les inuit n'en est en fait
à la piste comme vous il s'est présenté
en ce moment au centre du théâtre
d'aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'à la
mi-février alors à la happy faire
silence pour entendre ce qu'il y a deux
mots c'est une expression and i know
petit e fait beau et en fait ça décrit
bien je trouve le projet artistique
c'est alors c'est avant tout un balado
qui est diffusé donc et en kits
disponibles en ligne sur ici première
depuis la semaine dernière c'est un
format du canada aux musulmans et puis
donc à la basse et une cocréation du
collectif à la pique est formée de sept
jeunes inuits du nunavik le balado donc
comme je l'écrivais été réalisée par
marie-laurence ce rancourt qui la
cofondatrice de magnéto un organisme de
création radio et le projet prend aussi
la forme d'une pièce de théâtre donc qui
est présente au théâtre d'aujourd'hui
et la mise en scène de marie laurence
dauphinais à la base le projet avait été
présenté l'année dernière comme
laboratoire de création way of thé
acquis et le festival d'arts vivants qui
a toujours lieu en marge du festival
transamériques oui donc mais depuis
cette première mouture le projet a
beaucoup évolué on sait plus du tout la
même la même forme
ok alors le bal à dos et avant tout donc
c'est un format d'une heure c'est un
outil tout en français et en anglais et
je dirais que c'est quand même assez
rare de voir un balados transposer sur
les planches et se rendre jusqu'au
théâtre mais je dirais pas adapté
parce que dans la pièce de théâtre le
bal à dos est vraiment centrale si on
est presque comme un personnage et et
don fait à partir du balado qu'on a créé
la pièce de théâtre en fait c'est
vraiment venu en forme ans et l'un est
venu avec l'autre mais le point départ
et c'est vraiment de la daube exactement
donc je vous explique un peu comment sa
soeur qu'esprit marie-laurence rancourt
donc et laurence dauphinais se sont
tournés vers le collège montmorency à
laval où il ya beaucoup de jeunes
d'étudiants inuit qui vont poursuivre
leurs études après le secondaire
oui hélas elles ont fait un appel de
propositions ils ont demandé à deinove
est à des étudiants de s'il y en avait
qui est intéressé à participer à un
projet documentaire radio c'est encore
très générale et de cet appel de
propositions ces cinq jeunes chinois qui
se sont portés volontaires le hasard a
fait que ça se retrouve à être des
femmes
et puis donc mélodies audry akinésie
louisa et samantha donc cinq jeunes
femmes jeunes du jeune femme parce que
bon début vingtaine
début trentaine donc encore en dessous
de 30 ans et même 19 ans et 19 et puis
la plus vieille 32 ans actuellement il
me semble puis donc qui viennent toutes
de donka qu'oliver que pouvait on est ok
ça louit ou de l'avic et je dirais que
c'est pas ces balades oh c'est pas un
documentaire à proprement parler sur le
nord j'irai plus que c'est une porte
d'entrée vers le nord qui a été produite
par des gens du nord
c'est vraiment comme un accès vers le
nunavik finalement et les la production
a vraiment tenu à confier le micro à ses
à ces jeunes femmes pour leur laisser la
liberté de de discuter ensemble
d'échanger sur leur vision du nord sur
leur quotidien mais vraiment leur
laisser l'idée de laisser libre cours à
leur imagination pour orienter leurs
discussions et leur poser des questions
vraiment très ciblée donc nuit elles ont
été dirigées mais pas au moyen d'une
pour moyen d'une pièce de théâtre
conventionnel par exemple une mise en
scène on exactement c'est ça bien défini
donc les thèmes si vous voulez qu'on
retrouve bon c'est la relation avec la
nature
la relation avec le sud du québec et
puis justement l'identité qui vient avec
tout ça parce qu'il y en a dont mais je
pense à mélodie du plessis qui est né
d'une mère et nous est d'un père non
autochtone qui viennent de laval il me
semble qu'on peut et puis donc c'est sur
ce genre de thématique les jeunes femmes
vont vont échanger puis tout ça
accompagné de son ambiance typiquement
nordique donc je pense à le son du vent
sur les façades des maisons sur pilotis
le craquement des mets pas sur la neige
on peut justement peut-être en écouter
un extrait un extrait pour voulu nous
donner une image une image représente
alors on est commun dans un hangar où on
est en plein changement de mode de vie
de style de vie
il y a cinq générations la première
génération c c'est mes arrière grands
parents
c'est le début avec la compagnie de la
baie du sang il commençait peu à peu
s'installer c'est là que y ont vraiment
commencé à côtoyer avec les blancs les
minarets
ensuite il y a mes grands-parents l'eau
il était rendu pas mal sédentaires les
maisons construire les écoles comment
s'est construite aussi
ensuite il ya le mélo fingers ça c est
la génération de mes parents
pas beaucoup de vie traditionnel et pas
beaucoup de vies modernes ont plus
l'oeil on vraiment connu la drogue et
l'alcool
ensuite il ya ma génération ont grandi
avec des parents qui sont comme montmelo
finger on est fier d'être qui on est
donc on vienne entend mener le dit
plessis donc 32 ans qui viennent à
kuljic
c'est intéressant par ses luttes on voit
un peu cette fierté
donc quand elle parle de sa génération
cette fierté de cette génération de
d'abord appris de leurs parents et de
leurs grands parents mais aussi ce désir
de voir grand de voyages et de
poursuivre leurs études elles deux un
moment donné on est de plus en plus ça
c'est ça parce qu'il faut savoir que
pour poursuivre les études d aller au
cégep et à l'université il faut aller
dans des communautés dans le sud du
québec
oui on donc j'y suis et de sa communauté
et puis mais de plus en plus de nous et
qui qui poursuivent leurs études puis
donc toutes ces thématiques leur
finalement sont abordés mais de manière
très aléatoire très libre puis les fils
interview les unes les autres
une phrase que j'ai trouvé très
intéressante qui met le didier à un
moment donné c je suis inuit je suis
québécoise je suis les deux je suis pas
trop certaines qui je suis mais avec
celle son bien et il ya ce désir
d'apprendre à se trouver se comprendre
mieux s'affirmer
justement dans cette génération que
seuil entre nous
la culture du sud si on peut on peut
dire et la culture d'une oui mais alors
comment la pièce de théâtre s'intègre à
ça alors
alors c'est ça non plus que pendant la
crise hauteur on entend tout le balade
ou alors le bardo on est presque comme
un personnage une erreur on est vraiment
dans un espèce de voyage sonore le
spectateur quand on regarde regarde là
la scène en fait une scénographie très
simple c'est une maison on est à
l'extérieur de cette maison est à
l'intérieur de cette maison il ya deux
jours 18 qui sont pas du tout dans le
bal à dos c'est des artistes visuels
anact hutue et nancy centers qui
viennent le coup jack c'est pas de
femmes qui maîtrisaient les arts de la
scène qui était qu'avec l'expérience en
théâtre en jeu mais cela diez avait
quand même la fibre artistique dont elle
savait un peu l'application qui vient
avec bon la production d'une partie
et puis elle ne joue pas à proprement
parler j'ai donc on peut les voir sur la
droite dans tout le zag auch est donc là
on le voit on est à l'extérieur d'une
fenêtre de la face à envoie la façade de
la maison et de là c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit le baladeur on en est presque
comme un personnage parce qu'elle
l'écoutent elles interagissent avec de
temps à autre et on est vraiment comme
c'est très contemplatif mais je dirais
même sens mais presque 6 et immersif
parler tous les tous les médiums
fusionne les uns contre les autres et
pourquoi le bal à dos pendant tout ça
c'est c'est aussi un clin d'oeil aux
radios communautaires qui sont très
central dans les communautés du nord les
radios communautaires servent servent de
ces c'est un moyen d'écouter de la
musique oui mais aussi si on se met des
dessins transmettre des messages
et puis échangé échanger sur les
les alertes les alertes météo de chassey
puis % vu exactement le bingo par les
politiques régionales
donc c'est vraiment comme il disait
marie-laurence là encore parler de lien
social
d'où l'idée de cette balade aux qui
pourrait aussi central ici alors ce
spectacle là en fait la pièce de théâtre
elle est allée présenter ou alors sens
du théâtre d'aujourd'hui sur la rue
saint denis c'est juste causé depuis le
25 janvier c'est juste mon 16 février
puis une supplémentaire qui a été
ajoutée le 9 février à l'appui le balado
lui on peut l'entendre donc en ligne
l'application ici première ou sur le
site web exactement quand vous entendez
ça quand tu entends sèche je suis
incorrigible
qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire d'entendre
comme ça ces jeunes se raconte et
raconte et leur univers leur façon de
vivre
ben je trouve que ben moi en tant que
artiste s'est jamais savoir ce que les
autres font parce que une fois il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a dit genre à ma
création
c'est mon esprit qui est qui qui parle
avec ton esprit puis je trouve ça assez
- cé c'est important de partager comme
ça la culture par l'art et tout parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on compte que les
jeux les autres nous et nous écoutent
mieux on sait c'est vrai alors si on a
envie de te voir là on a donc plusieurs
lieux on va pouvoir mettre les adresses
des endroits où tu exposé entre autres
on peut aller se promener à montréal
pour aller voir également cette grande
murale d'alanis obomsawin merci mekkid
est passé par notre studio c'est de
m'avoir invité est venu parler de toi
avant de partir dans 20 ans tu te vois
où est tu vois ta communauté tu vois les
autochtones ou dans 20 ans ben dans 20
ans j'espère qu'on aurait ce genre
renversé
tout le le climat qui est en train
d'être un état d'urgence puis sinon
genre dans 20 ans je me vois
je sais pas j'ai pas trop penser à ce
jour
merci beaucoup merci merci charme en
somme une fois cette semaine à la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup matiz
des de nous parler dallas a pillé d'une
colonie et entre-temps moi je vous
invite bien sûr aller sur notre site
espace autochtone à aller découvrir tous
ces jeunes ces jeunes autochtones de
moins de 30 ans qui ont des choses à
raconter qu'ils ont des choses à nous
apprendre et qui vont devenir les
citoyens de demain des citoyens
important merci beaucoup
bonne semaine
[Musique]